so in related news
to the the the death of expertise the
disregard for science and data and
research
is that the fact that the international
governmental panel on climate change
released its long-awaited report just
the other day
and before i get to some of the key
findings that i find interesting and
alarming i want to talk about an aspect
of american culture that exists within
evangelical christianity
there's this pastor named perry stone
and we're going to get to a clip of him
but
coming from this faith tradition i was
raised an evangelical christian a
conservative christian nationalist if
you will
and
when i was when i was coming up in the
church it was
it was
taught that god gave man dominion over
the earth and because of that we needed
to be good stewards
of god's creation the planet
and it doesn't seem to be that way
anymore
perry stone here who isn't some no-name
you may not know who he is but he's got
a youtube channel of like 650 000 people
he's the leader of a congregation people
listen to him they look up to him they
admire him
they honor him with leadership
and he is saying in this clip i'm
getting ready to play
screw it let it burn
yeah climate change real but we don't
care because jesus is coming back in
revelation chapter 20 when christ comes
back to earth and sets up his kingdom
he's going to change
everything and there's going to be a
thousand years of peace and so the sons
of god and these are the children of god
these are believers who return with
christ who set up the kingdom for a
thousand years we're going to see a
complete change in the earth and that
what we call the travail of creation or
the travel of the earth will cease when
the messiah returns so those who
criticize believers now for not being
you know environmentally concerned or
whatever we know how the book ends we
know where this is going we know how in
the end when messiah comes back look
folk can i say something to you and say
it in love it's wonderful to do all that
we can to help the planet but at the
same time if you know what the prophecy
says you know what's coming and you know
that real peace real joy and and
everything that men want will only
happen with the return of the messiah
and you can see that all through the
book of zechariah you can see it in the
writings of isaiah and that messiah
without a doubt is one man and it's
jesus christ that is alarming
that is an admission that yeah listen a
lot of christians we just don't care
about it because we're waiting for jesus
our faith
is
paramount to anything else
we're gambling on the fact that jesus is
going to be coming back to save us
so let it burn
that is that is a remarkable admission
that i believe is held by millions of
people
and it is
very difficult
to pry that viewpoint away from people
when when it is not substantiated by
fact
when it is only an emotional response
to
what is happening in our world
and let's talk a little bit about what's
happening in our world specifically some
of the key findings of the ipcc report
one
is that
humans are to blame
for for climate change without a doubt
we are in a situation now where it
cannot be denied
reading from this article from reuters
the intergovernmental panel on climate
change the ipcc used its strongest terms
yet to assert that humans are causing
climate change
with the first line of its report
summary reading quote
it is unequivocal that human influence
has warmed the atmosphere ocean
and land
it is unequivocal
the stark language marked a shift from
previous ipcc reports which had said it
was extremely likely that industrial
activity was to blame
there is no uncertainty language in this
sentence because there is no uncertainty
that global warming is caused by human
activity and the burning of fossil
that was the
the ipcc co-author
um frederic otto he's a climatologist at
the university of oxford
these are learned individuals
they are well versed in climatology
they're not
making wild claims like a mike lindell
with zero expertise
these people have dedicated their lives
to one single topic
to get it right
to be an expert
not to be fueled by dunning-kruger mania
another key takeaway
is that the temperatures are going to
continue to rise
even the severest of cuts are unlikely
to prevent global warming of 1.5 degrees
celsius over pre-industrial temperatures
without immediate steep emissions cuts
though average temperatures could cruise
past two degrees celsius by the end
of the century
that is scary
and it may seem like a long ways away
the end of the century
but
if you're getting ready to have a kid
they could very well be alive then
we're talking about
protecting the climate and the planet
for posterity's sake
this is a literal
existential crisis that we're facing
what's the saying about uh it's an
honorable man who plants a tree the
shade of which he'll never enjoy
i'm sure i botched it but it's something
like that
and are we gonna be the perry stones of
the world or are we gonna plant trees
the shade of which we'll never enjoy
another
key finding here is one that we all are
witnessing in real time
and that that is that extreme weather
events are getting more and more common
and more
and more extreme
they can tie this to what's called
attribution science it's no longer
guessing whether or not uh climate
change is is the responsibility is the
the triggering factor for the wildfires
here in california or in australia or
anywhere else around the world
it's no longer up in the air whether
flooding events
are caused
by
the climate change they know now
attribution science
that's something you should familiarize
yourself with
in the past people would say you can't
say anything about any individual event
said ipcc co-author michael weiner a
climate scientist at the lawrence
berkeley national laboratory in
california
but now we can actually make
quantitative statements about extreme
weather events
this is serious
now listen the report does say
that where we if we were to to stop it
that some of these changes are going to
happen whether we we could go to zero
carbon emission right now and some of
these changes are still going to take
place
but they're saying it's not too late
this is an extreme problem
i believe it's going to take extreme
measures
to get it under control
whether that be the new green new deal
whether that be some of the the
initiatives that biden has proposed
but it's going to take more than just
letting it burn because of jesus
that is a fact